all right another week another loki
video episode five we're almost at the
end there's one
left and this was loki in purgatory and
as always spoiler warning i get
spoilerish when i talk about episodes of
television shows
not gonna be a play-by-play but you know
some things i found interesting that are
spoilers so last week on loki loki got
pruned mobius got pruned everyone's
pruned turns out yeah
this place is where people who get hit
with those vaporizing sticks
they don't get vaporized they don't die
they go to the set of the last of us
where the smoke monster from lost
eats them but loki's are crafty so there
are a lot of loki's
in this world well i mean there's a few
loki's and then they get to the loki
lair
and then another loki shows up with a
bunch of followers he has these
sycophants with him which
gonna be completely real that loki is
more like the loki i thought we were
going to see
when the show was announced i like that
loki i was like hey you can go ahead and
replace
nerfed loki and then you know left the
show and the show does a thing like when
loki was talking was like hey do we have
one of those
quantum leap portal devices or like oh
yeah totally they're everywhere
idiot but sylvie gets her hands on one
and i was like why doesn't she just
prune herself that that's what a
oh whoa she did just now well there you
go cool i don't know it just made sense
i was like are they not gonna do that
thing and i'm gonna about why they
didn't oh sweet they did
awesome i i get to talk about how smart
that was that she did that and that's
pretty much this episode everyone gets
to this purgatory planet they're like
hey we have to get past smoke monster
and that's what they do so when the
quest of them like hey we gotta get past
smoke monster and find out what's going
on
old loki's like we're staying here this
is our home i was like
what this i mean i get home is
where the heart is no way your heart's
here this is it like this is the apex
we're getting to the point where you
might be able to get out and go anywhere
you're just choosing this place
overall this is it this is the
flosston's paradise
of the multiverse i call so
that was weird but i'm glad he came back
to help then again like all he did was
say no i'm staying here
and then left for a second i was like i
guess i'll help him so he could have
just been like i'll go with you and help
you but dude recreates asgard
and distracts the dragon smoke monster
enough for them to be like hey i guess
we're super powerful let's
link hands and i guess they just kind of
destroyed the smoke monster he just
popped he went
done part the clouds like the red sea
behold your goal
a haunted castle in the middle of the
maze it looks like a witch lives there
or something bring on those doctor doom
theories
and then yeah old loki dies but dragon
just comes down and kills him which in a
world where i'm pretty convinced that
loki like tom hiddleston loki is gonna
die in next week's episode
if old loki were out like more of a boss
than loki loki i just i don't know i'd
find that weird taking smoke dragon to
the face
or however hiddleston loki goes out who
has it better
or actually just thought of this because
of old loki's story and him talking
about how he
went and settled down and tried to keep
quiet i feel like that might be
foreshadowing
for loki and we'll think he dies and
then there's going to be a post credit
scene where he's hanging out on some
beach somewhere
next week is the week where we get
answers and i hope we get it like
obviously we're gonna get answers but i
hope we get the answers
some of the questions the show just has
at the top of the list of things next
week will
definitely answer is why you know i'm
looking forward to figuring out or
finding out why you know like why
the big elaborate scheme why when you
hit someone with the stick and prune
them
does it not just kill them it sends them
to this place that looks like a set
piece from the last of us
where the love child of the langoliers
and the smoke monster from lost just
comes to eat you so that smoke monster
has to live on souls right like eating
variants must
fuel something what is it fuel because
if you're just trying to eliminate
people and kill them there's no way
all of that is more efficient than say a
bullet to the head in a wood chipper you
know there are easier ways so there's
that
also i hope that the other loki's in
this world get
used i mean it's it's a ripe world of
loki's including but not limited to
that loki that is in the thumbnail of
this episode
on disney plus site and we live in a
world where if you have that quantum
leap data pad
like mobius did you just get out of this
place and go back to the tva
why wouldn't he just go back there
gather up a bunch of those data pads
and then hit himself again you know like
prune himself go back there and just
hand them out to everybody like here you
go loki's there you go actual loki that
feels like loki with
the election badge go back to the tva
raise some hell
have fun with that and good luck with
that tva i remember burning it all to
the ground anyway right
it makes sense to do that so i feel like
they should be used more in next week's
episode when we find out
the great and powerful oz like who's the
one running the show mr flibble running
the multiverse i mean i myself have had
my ups and downs with this show but
in the end the intrigue of who is
in that castle who's beyond the veil
who's running the puppet show
that's a really intriguing question and
it could be a really epic reveal it
could be a reveal that
sets up this next phase of the mcu or it
could be a throwaway joke it's the mcu
we don't know but as for you good folks
loki episode 5 have you seen it what did
you think about it or who do you think
it is
running this multiverse tva facade bring
on the mephisto comments but whoever you
think it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you